okay as many of you know I am NOT a
socialist I am a social democrat that
probably doesn't come as a shock to
people who have been watching the show
or listening to the show for a while
Social Democrats are capitalists in the
sense that we are not trying to
overthrow capitalism and replace it with
socialism or Marxism or communism or
some system in which there's no more
private property private businesses etc
we recognize the many many many failings
of capitalism but we want to fix them
and one of the reasons that capitalism
has to be fixed
is that it doesn't work for tons of
people but the interesting thing about
this is that if you want some form of
capitalism to remain you had better damn
well fix it because the longer and
longer it goes without working for
millions and millions and millions of
people it makes the system more at risk
of being overthrown by some other system
this was the concept in fact of Marxism
that eventually there would be this
uprising of the proletariat that would
take down the bourgeoisie of course it
has not happened in the United States
but the worst capitalism is the more
likely that that becomes that gets us to
today's sort of news which is that case
in point there's a new poll which says
seven out of ten Millennials would vote
for a socialist candidate I do wonder
whether the people responding to the
poll actually know what socialism is
because it seems like lots of people
talk about socialism and they don't
actually know what it is but let's
assume for a second just for the sake of
discussion because the analysis is still
an interesting one this poll was
released yesterday it finds 70 percent
of Millennials are either somewhat or
extremely likely to vote for a socialist
political candidate 50 percent of
Millennials have a somewhat or very
unfavorable view of capitalism which is
up from last year overall capitalism is
still viewed more favorably than other
economic systems 61 percent positive but
this is a very clear
even if many of these people are mixing
up socialism and social democracy the
trend line is clear and this is why
Social Democrats who are for better
regulated social capitalism need to fix
capitalism and by the way not that I'm
in the vulture capitalist free-market
lays a fair type of camp if you're a
vulture capitalist and you want to keep
some form of capitalism this should be a
wake-up call for you as well this is why
you need to be fixing capitalism with
the socially democratic reforms that
people on the left of the Democratic
Party have been talking about for many
years the least damaging thing to a
capitalist is to fix capitalism or they
risk some other system actually becoming
something people really and truly want
you know when Donald Trump says during
his State of the Union we will never be
a capital of socialist country he
doesn't know that as I've said before
things change in countries they can
change slowly they can change more
quickly than sometimes we believe is
possible but the reality is that there's
no real risk right now of the u.s.
becoming actually socialist you know
college tuition paid through taxes is
not socialism Medicare for all isn't
socialism gun controls not socialism but
the right has both successfully and
unsuccessfully used the term socialism
as an argument to attack these socially
democratic policies but eventually
there's going to have to be some
accounting because as capitalism as we
know it continues to fail more and more
people and fail to provide a basic
standard of living and allow these just
sickening excesses of wealth to
accumulate more and more and more at the
top Millennials who see that system as
failing them why wouldn't they be open
to some other system they don't see all
of the great things that capitalism is
bringing them because it's arguably not
brought them a lot of great things so of
course they're going to look at
something else because our version of
capitalism is fundamentally broken so if
you really
without the benefits of capitalism and
by this I mean some of the main tenants
right private property private business
ownership taxation which tends to be
progressive taxation although you know
different people argue about how
progressive it should be lots of the
things that we have if you want to
really make the case that it's working
you've got to make it work for more
people and that includes making sure no
one drops below a certain standard of
living that includes cutting down on the
corrosive influence of money in politics
and an influence peddling the data is
increasingly clear on this something
will have to be done or other systems
even misunderstood systems and this is
why I said you know a lot of people
don't know the different don't realize
what socialism actually is it doesn't
matter because no matter what your
assessment is of what capitalism is and
what socialism is if people understand
that the system as it exists is not
working for them it becomes harder and
harder to argue that this is the system
that we should keep